y damos paso a la actualización de la
información económica con jorge hurtado
jorge un saludo nuevamente para ustedes
y comenzamos con la que ha sido la
noticia de la última jornada la reserva
federal de eeuu que ya se pronunció
sobre la inflación de eeuu que sabemos
es la más alta en los últimos 40 años
así es y bueno aunque ahora se dejó sin
algún cambio en los tipos de interés ya
prometieron que se aumentara a partir de
marzo en una rueda de prensa el
presidente de la institución de ramón
power aclaró que a finales de este mes
terminará las compras de activos también
en el mercado interpretó del anuncio con
que la fed sería más agresiva en el
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
de lo que se esperaba el aumento de las
tasas se traduce en menos disponibilidad
de préstamos para viviendas carros a un
negocio para algunos economistas la
preocupación es que la reserva federal
esté actuando un poco tarde para
combatir la inflación otros dicen que
les preocupa que sus políticas sean
demasiado drástica y causen algún tipo
de desequilibrio en los mercados
internacionales escuchemos que dijo el
presidente de la fed
y el comité de la reserva federal
mantuvo su política de tipos de interés
cerca de cero y estableció que sus
expectativas de que un incremento en
estos tipos será apropiado pronto el
comité también aceptó continuar
reduciendo su compra neta de activos en
línea con el cronograma anunciado en
diciembre finalizando la así a
principios de marzo tienen rey march
jorge en singapur s se convirtió en el
primer miembro asociado de la alianza
del pacífico así es ángel ayer se firmó
un acuerdo de libre comercio con la
alianza del pacífico que es integrada
por colombia méxico perú y chile en la
reunión que asiste el presidente de
colombia y perú ecuador chile y el
ministro de hacienda de méxico este
acuerdo busca cooperación en sectores
claves para la economía como la energía
la infraestructura en el área digital
los alimentos así como también impulsar
la logística marítima y portuaria según
el comunicado oficial este intercambio
comercial entre los cuatro países de la
alianza del pacífico y singapur fue de
6.100 millones de dólares en 2019 según
los datos oficiales otra edición para
esta alianza podría ser ecuador cuyo
presidente guillermo lasso se mostró
confiado en lograrlo a corto plazo
escuchemos un poco las declaraciones de
esta reunión de presidentes ayer
a singapur con su experiencia con su
tradición como los principales centros
de innovación ciencia y tecnología del
planeta llega también con un valioso
aporte en la cuarta revolución
industrial pero también llega para
enriquecer la relación de comercio e
inversión siendo uno de los líderes
mundiales en logística portuaria y en
logística de comercio exterior la
noticia que venimos comentando desde
temprano porque el fondo monetario
internacional le pidió a el salvador que
revierta su polémica ley de bitcoin así
es el director pidió el directorio pidió
al gobierno salvadoreño dejar de usar el
bitcoin como moneda en curso legal
debido a los peligros para la
estabilidad financiera la integridad
financiera y la protección del
consumidor así dice el organismo también
como posibles contingencias fiscales
incluso el fm y expresó preocupación por
la emisión de bonos respaldados con la
script o moneda que el gobierno en allí
porque le pretende lanzar a partir de
febrero y marzo de este año el bitcoin
que es la cripto moneda más famosa
perdió su valor en aproximadamente un 50
desde el máximo histórico que vivió en
noviembre pasado esto significa en la
que el tesoro salvadoreño ha perdido
cerca de 22 millones de dólares de sus
reservas según la agencia de
calificación moody's pero escuchemos qué
opinan los salvadoreños ahora que el
este organismo internacional está
solicitando dejar de usar el bitcoin
como moneda oficial
pues no nos afectaría realmente porque
ya la gente ya sabe que aceptamos
bitcoin ya sabe que puedan dar su dinero
seguro su teléfono
ya como que sería un paso para como para
retroceder nuevamente porque fíjense que
para mí me da igual qué es lo que tengo
este porque para mí no es ningún
beneficio eso yo aquí vengo a trabajar
solo con el dólar bitcoin lo acepto yo y
un conflicto que usted nos voy a
explicar en la unión europea defendió a
lituania en su postura frente a taiwán
así es en el premio de la organización
mundial del comercio del bloque europeo
abrir un procedimiento contra china por
prácticas que considera discriminatoria
hacia lituania lituania enfurecida china
en julio pasado al abrir una oficina de
taiwán un territorio con gobierno
autónomo que beijing considera rebelde
escuchemos un poco
resolución de
esfuerzo las prácticas coercitivas de
china contra lituania y también contra
los exportadores de otros países que
muestran contenido lituano en sus
cadenas de valor esas prácticas
coercitivas continúan por eso lanzamos
ahora este caso en la organización pero
como he dicho paralelamente continuamos
también nuestros esfuerzos de
desescalada
no siendo más jorge nos vemos mañana
[Música]